and again flame yeah the one that named
I cannot pronounce okay let's go Knight
f3 and I don't really want to see what
is this fall okay I'm happy I'm happy to
take the center if I must learn on both
push it must look good yeah you always
play down on the snake benoni and now he
switches to some non snake benoni that
that looks a bit strange with the bishop
on e7 okay oh gotcha I could have waited
until a six until you six have a six
happens but ok wants to play Bishop to
f6 it's not going to prevent that are
going to be able to implement that hmm i
wonder if i should go for central
expansion here or just play solidly with
pieces
yeah let's go let's go solid him I don't
know wasn't sure hmm interesting
that shouldn't be too bad the f4
expansion is a little bit easier to do
if there's no bishop even though of
course trading as in general something
that black welcomes in a bin only
structure
maybe here even I don't know hmm 55
immediately is a bit much maybe here
ruki aight i can go now maybe not i
thought 'if I've takes the six but that
is not threatening much
okay so five Jake's 94 that's not
convincing have to have to move the
Queen up away from the e-file
well Center a breakthrough it's not easy
to engineer here I probably have to play
this in a more sophisticated way somehow
before I want to take play before
they're only fears that my position is a
big loose button ok this is ok for me
definitely unless I'm overlooking a
tactic but I don't think I do now that
looks fine if I can get in Bishop d7 c6
it can be really nice actually would
make some sense of that slightly weird
bishop on g4 yeah we get is wrong it's
not a badly placed piece it's just a bit
unusual
and now I laga ke five he might take
anyway let's go sorry let's go to the a
file so maybe shoot for OK seven some
mobile maybe what absolutely should not
happen is that my center gets blown up
but some kind of f5 or something like
that that would be really awful
okay okay seven maybe still shoot for
some beef 5pm it's difficult to make
progress a little bit
this is irritating I'd like to know five
after all I have some issues to make
progress in really have if I go look at
seven year old maybe take play kuna have
six this is what irritates me a little
bit him but life is not easy for black
either okay so he's he's blinking first
this should be really nice now mission
coming to 28 to here which has been
basically giving up the FL
one moment here
Luke s7 is also pretty attractive
looking move that's also a good move I
guess okay so what is this 96,000 95
I'm wait and take stakes 95 takes a 697
shine time morning check check check I'm
stopping the pawn Rukia c7 is to go back
check promotes III and close it's very
close that I could actually take them
so my king is stopping his porn and a
head would be seven coming so i hope
that wins
check now led wins I'm promoting
didn't even see that I 125 seconds I'll
still thinking is there any of time but
I did not have it um okay interesting
game this benoni structure yeah
somewhere around here i thought i should
be ok but wow engine gives you five is
winning almost Wow is that so strong ok
I saw that but I didn't see why this is
so great yet hive is very strong it
seems why is that so strong alright
that's difficult to do look you one and
this seems to be very strong yeah it is
what the engine is giving as a line
which seems to win forward well now
cannot not in a blitz game I mean I saw
a five and 94 words couldn't figure that
out again you five is strong g6 yeah I
wasn't sure because I'm not even
threatening much to take if he plays
like this but 94 I struggling the Queen
actually funny okay so some good
opportunities here I went for that
strategic way to do it and he missed
Queen default check here check txtx
takes
this which is which is equal ish okay
but I think after this I should be
better i believe that structure normally
is good for an advantage yeah yeah but
slow I know what this is this i wasn't
sure i was thinking that maybe this is
interesting now but that's levy 50 so I
was just doing small things here and
well he blinked first in a way after
that i'm i'm winning with my bishop
there okay Sam is this yeah yeah i
wasn't sure i was looking at this but
it's not working i think due to rue k7 I
saw the c7.r ooh k 8 chantix Jaclyn like
I know his pawn is pushing through even
though the engine says that King of two
is totally winning I have time to stop
the porn but the whole thing still
didn't work because after this this
black has c3 and black wins so I'm glad
I didn't do that this is this also
should be good yeah it is winning just
check I'm quick enough with my phone
porn at the seaport is stopped rather
comfortably okay that was a decent game
I missed a couple of chances but well
you cannot see it all and if you keep
some kind of advantage it's usually good
enough very often some mistake will help
you okay thanks for watching